نشرت وسائل الإعلام التابعة للدولة مقطع فيديو لمجموعة
من الفتيات شوهدن يدخلن
قطار المترو، وبدا أن بعض الفتيات الداخلات
لم يرتدين الحجاب
في هذا الفيديو، وتتهم مجموعات الناشطين الإيرانيين
شرطة الآداب
بالاعتداء على فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا في أحد الشوارع.
محطة مترو تان لعدم ارتدائها
الحجاب الإلزامي أو غطاء الرأس
بعد لحظات، تظهر مجموعة
من الفتيات يحملن جارافان خارج
قطار المترو ويضعنها على الرصيف،
لا يمكن رؤية أي مشاجرة في هذا
الفيديو المعدل الذي تم نشره على الولاية
وسائل الإعلام لم نتمكن من تأكيد
صحتها، كما يقول النشطاء
إن أرميتا جارافان كانت في غيبوبة
منذ يوم الأحد وفقًا
لمجموعة المعارضة الناشطة إيران سلك، وقد تم
إدخالها إلى المستشفى بسبب صدمة في الرأس،
ولم نتمكن بعد من
التحقق من ذلك بشكل مستقل  معلومات قال الرئيس التنفيذي
لمترو [ __ ] لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية إنه
لم يكن هناك أي تفاعل جسدي أو لفظي
بين موظفيه وحكومة
إيران